we can't wait for you and Kristoff to
get married on up we know that he keeps
trying to propose to you in frozen - and
once he finally does we know you'll say
yes the two of you are still young but
eventually you'll probably start a
family and onna you're going to be such
a great mom we hope that one day we get
to see your adorable kids building a
snowman with Olaf have you ever wondered
what some of the Disney Princesses would
be like as parents keep watching to find
out what Anna and Kristoff children
would look like and whether or not
they'll have powers like they're on Elsa
Rapunzel we know that Rapunzel marries
Eugene because we saw their wedding in
tangled ever after these two are going
to be the most loving parents ever
they both had tough childhoods Eugene
grew up in an orphanage so he didn't get
a lot of attention
Rapunzel of course grew up with Mother
Gothel and Gothel only pretended to love
Rapunzel to manipulate her Rapunzel
would never do that to her kids she
would also never lock them away because
she hated living in her tower she would
make sure they had tons of adventures
Eugene loves being rich so he would
spoil them run Rapunzel would also teach
them to be kind and to never judge a
book by its cover some of their most
loyal friends were really scary-looking
Rapunzel would encourage her kids to
have lots of hobbies just like she did
Rapunzel and Eugene would also have the
cutest kids these two are just so cute
together of course it will rub off on
their kids we love this fan art from
deviant artists low coat a look how
happy Rapunzel and Eugene look as
parents it's so sweet
Tiana while Rapunzel might be a
free-spirited mom Princess Tiana would
have a different approach to parenting
Tiana was raised to be a hard worker and
she would absolutely raise her kids the
same way her children would be doing
chores from a very early age she would
want them to learn to take care of
themselves she would love them dearly
but she would make sure they bought
their own battles she would help them
set goals and learn how to achieve them
now her husband would have a totally
different approach Naveen would be the
fun parent who lets the kids eat ice
cream for dinner he would stop Tiana
from being too serious and we bet those
kids would turn into awesome cook
check out this adorable fan art from
deviant artists Amitha 101
Tiana would definitely have her kids in
the kitchen helping when they're little
it's a great way to bond with them now
we know mal might not be one of the
classic Disney Princesses but she was
the daughter of a fairy queen and she is
going to be the queen of auradon like
Tiana and Naveen mal and Ben might have
some different approaches to parenting
mal is going to be a very different
parent than Maleficent he's amazing
she's going to make sure her kids always
know that she loves them and she'll
probably teach them how to get into some
trouble mal won't want her kids to be
too spoiled since they're growing up in
auradon she knows that her tough life on
the Isle is what made her strong so
she'll also encourage her kids to visit
the Isle weekly mal will make sure that
her youngsters know where their mom came
from then on the other hand will want to
spoil his kids he'll be such a fun dad
and their children are going to be the
best-dressed kids in auradon with Evie
as their aunt check out our edgy picture
of mouth then and their oldest daughter
what an adorable family jasmine
we totally loved the new version of
Aladdin princess jasmine is so awesome
in it documen would be such a great mom
even though she's busy ruling Agrabah
she would still make plenty of time for
her kids she would teach them how to be
strong caring rulers she wouldn't lock
them away in the palace because she
knows how lonely that can be Aladdin
would probably do most of the boring
parenting stuff like diapers and snacks
Jasmine is a busy ruler after all these
two would take their kids on family
trips on the magic carpet Jasmine would
make sure that Rajah the tiger protects
her kids and Abu would make sure that
they got into a little trouble check out
this sweet fan art from dark matter Nova
on deviantART Jasmine would sing to her
kids just like her mom saying to her
onna we're starting to notice a trend
with the princesses who were locked away
from the world that brings us to Anna
from frozen
she and Kristoff makes such a cute
couple and they're going to be amazing
parents Anna will be such a fun mom
she'll never want her kids to be as
bored as she was growing up she'll play
with them all the time
her kids will grow up having their mom
as their best friend they'll know that
they can come to her with anything
because Ana's got
her emotions under rats Christophe will
be a super hands-on dad he didn't have a
family when he was growing up so he'll
be super loving one of Ana's daughters
will probably take after on Elsa and
develop some super cool powers of her
own but this time Elsa will be there to
teach her how to control them
we love this precious drawing from D be
an artist nightlight which Disney
Princess would you want as a parent let
us know in the comment section below
thanks for watching give this video a
big thumbs up and don't forget to
subscribe we'll see you next time on the
things
[Music]